hey Vsauce Michael here with a special
video today this video is my submission
to Google demo slam and the technology
I'm using is personalized Google
homepage
I took 29 pictures of myself in what are
clearly comfortable positions and then I
isolated each picture and I've uploaded
them sequentially to 29 different
browser windows I'm uploading the last
one right now and I'm gonna line it up
perfectly right on top of the other 28
yep 29 browser windows now all I have to
do is hold down the keyboard shortcut
for minimize and like a flipbook you'll
be able to watch me slam dunk a
basketball through the second oh and
Google looking good good form there's
the second oh and uh oh slam I'm not
very good at basketball
[Music]